Tom Friedman has been a columnist of the
New York Times for 25 years in that
quarter-century Friedman has raised
banality and cliche mongering to a kind
of art form like Picasso he wastes
nothing there is not a single piece of
mindless conventional wisdom floating
around Washington or New York City but
Tom Friedman hasn't managed to whip into
a hasty column at one time or another
naturally our ruling class who loves him
they consider him brilliant they read
Tom Friedman on the peloton every
morning and they feel affirmed he's as
dumb as they are we refer you to
Friedman's column this morning because
there is no question it is a taste of
things to come and very soon in that
column Friedman calls for Joe Biden to
skip the fall presidential debates for
cover Friedman adds a couple of silly
caveat Biden should only consider
debating he writes if Donald Trump
releases years of his personal tax
returns and then agrees to have a panel
of journalists sit on stage to call him
a liar in real time otherwise no
debating turns out Tom Friedman is not
really a genius so it's pretty obvious
what's going on here this is the most
cynical election strategy ever devised
or ever perpetrated on American voters
hide the candidate to Election Day the
country can find out what's the
administration after it's in power but
until then no appearing in public and my
god don't ever tell the truth so while
the Biden campaign take Tom Friedman's
advice well of course they will take it
because they have no choice Biden is up
in the polls as of right now so they
can't let him talk that could wreck
everything
people might discover that Joe Biden
bears no resemblance to the Joe Biden
they remember they would put seven
hundred and twenty million back a
million women back in the workforce I
love this place I look look what's not
to like about form on terms of the
beauty of it and what a neat town just
as brave just as talons white kids we
choose science over fiction we choose
truth over facts think about it
all these truths to be self-evident all
men and women created by goal you know
that you know the thing you know the
thing in fact we do know the thing but
poor Joe Biden does not know the thing
and at times Biden's doesn't seem to
know anything or even to recognize his
own wife
imagine Biden spending six hours on
stage with Donald Trump trading jabs on
live television
he can't do that so he's not going to do
that instead they're gonna keep Joe
Biden hidden behind the curtain he'll
read prepared speech from time to time
on a good day he can pull that off
but nothing extemporaneous are
off-the-cuff he's not capable of that
it's all pretty shocking if you think
about it we've kind of accepted it but
pull back a little bit they're running a
candidate for president who cannot
govern and they know that and they're
doing it anyway so what does that say
about the people around Joe Biden will
the ruthless obviously and they're not
in to debate not just presidential
debates but any debate they don't like
being disagreed with they don't believe
that there are two sides to any question
they believe their own views are the
only legitimate views when you criticize
them they won't engage with you they
don't bother to rebut your points they
simply attack you Joe Biden himself
attack this show today in fact he didn't
respond to the questions that we raised
he just called us names and then his
minions tried to pull us off the air we
survive because thank God we work here
but you should know that's how they plan
to run the country Biden will pick some
running mate whose identity makes it
impossible for anyone to criticize her
and then they'll describe any criticism
of their governance as a hate crime we
got a taste of that for eight years
under Barack Obama you know this you
know how it works and of course they've
been doing it for years on college
campuses and in corporate diversity
seminars any place where they have total
control now the entire American
population is getting the very same
treatment tonight for example close to a
thousand companies are boycotting
Facebook's advertising platform why are
they doing that because they're
demanding that Facebook censor the
president and his voters ban
conservative news outlets allow only
publications controlled by the left to
decide what's news
let's most anyway because there's only
one mass media company left in America
that consistently descents from the
left's view of things you're watching it
right now
what do you think they plan to do to Fox
News if they take power you can imagine
we're in their way so these people
aren't liberals we call them that but
they're not they don't wring their hands
and wonder what to do next like you're
flaky fifth grade teacher who wore
sandals and worried about the fate of
the baby harp seals we're gonna save the
whale sticker on a Volvo know they're
nothing like that
they're not sentimental these are
totalitarians they know exactly what
they want they don't wring their hands
they want power and they know how to get
power why are so many people being fired
right now for absurdly trivial offenses
liking the wrong tweet commenting on the
wrong post making the wrong hand gesture
accidentally why is that happening
simple to terrify the rest of us into
obedience we better not say that we
could be hurt too that's the lesson we
take as we watch people around us fired
and destroyed for doing very small
things that tells us that the people
around dope Joe Biden they're the ones
doing this ruled by fear they do not
rule by consent as you're supposed to in
this country they are in fact the true
enemies of democracy they don't care
what you think
and just in case the rest of us missed
the point they're working hard to make
self defense against their mobs their
militia a crime you cannot resist us and
we will prosecute you st. Louis Circuit
attorney Kim Gardner is threatening to
arrest mark and Patricia McCluskey for
daring to defend themselves against a
mob that was threatening to murder them
a mob of Democratic voters but they're
the criminals this is why the left wants
to abolish the police they're not
abolishing law enforcement they're
replacing them with a woke militia of
armed social workers psychologists and
ethnic studies majors obedient
Democratic voters and it's why in places
where the police still exist they want
to make certain you're too afraid to
call them in San Francisco supervisor
shaman Walton has introduced the caution
against racially exploitative
non-emergent
or Karen act hilarious if you think
about it a law we're told is against
hate that is named after a racial slur
but it's not actually that funny the
bill would make it eight hate crime for
citizens to call law enforcement based
on quote racial bias how exactly do you
think that law will be applied
you don't have to wonder call the police
because you're frightened of mostly
peaceful protesters threatening to kill
you
you're the criminal now and day by day
liberalism evaporates and the left
troops who called themselves liberals
children of the Enlightenment are
falling in line but behind what is
clearly a paragraph just today the
founder of voxcom Ezra Klein someone
regarded as an intellectual on the Left
went on Twitter to explain my free
speech is actually very bad quote a lot
of debates that sell themselves as being
about free speech are actually about
power and there's a lot of power in
being able to claim and hold the mantle
of free speech defender oh we see where
you're going
actually Ezra Klein is half right about
this free speech definitely is about
power power for people who don't have
any people like Ezra Klein want less
free speech for others so they can have
more power when they can tell you what
you can say what they're really telling
you is what you're allowed to believe
they're not controlling your mouth
they're controlling your mind and
there's no deeper control than that any
person who's telling you that is someone
you should be very afraid of